George Mason University and coordinator
of the Western civilization program at
the Smithsonian he spoke at the Center
for equal opportunity in Washington DC
good morning I'd like to welcome all of
you to the Center for equal
opportunities regular ongoing series of
book luncheons and we are very
privileged today to have with us
Arthur Herman who is the author of the
idea of decline in Western history
professor Herman is professor of history
at George Mason University he is also
the coordinator of the Western
civilization program at the Smithsonian
Institution and we are particularly
pleased to have prefers professor Herman
here today to talk about his book the
decline the idea of decline in Western
history there have been as all of you
know many books written over the years
about the decline of Western
civilization it is in fact an ongoing
theme in critiques of history and in a
series of books that have been popular
particularly within the last few years
Paul Kennedy's book even judge bork's
book slouching toward Gomorrah which has
dealt with the idea of decline in the
West and in the United States in
particular but professor Herman's book
is not technically speaking a book about
the decline of the West it is rather an
intellectual history about the idea of
decline in the West which i think is a
very important and subtle distinction
and I'd like to read just a paragraph
which I think says very well sums up
very well the thesis of professor
Herman's book and it is from his
introduction some people talk about the
decline of civilization others live it
this is a book about the origins and
diffusions of an intellectual tradition
the idea of the decline of the West we
will see how it formed the dark under
of modern European thought in the 19th
century and how it became arguably the
single most dominant and influential
theme in culture and politics in the
20th century not only has it affected
people's lives in unexpected and
startling ways which we will examine in
some detail but it may also be
inseparable from the idea of
civilization itself
professor Herman's book has met with
much critical acclaim and I'd like to
just read a few of the things that have
been said about it including one
statement by Gertrude Himmelfarb who is
an eminent historian herself and who
happens to be with us today and she
described the book as powerful and
persuasive Publishers Weekly described
the book in this way Herman takes us
through these heavy thoughts with great
panache and erudition a brisk and
cordial guide to the slough of despond
fred segal writing in the Weekly
Standard said his book should trigger a
long overdue scholarly debate and the
Los Angeles Times said it deserves a
significant audience and we are very
happy today to help provide some of that
audience in professor Herman will speak
for about 20 minutes and then we will
have questions and answers thank you
well I want to tell you that it's a real
pleasure to be here
this is a wonderful venue for me and
it's one that I would have would have
picked for myself even if Linda hadn't
invited me to come out here because I
think a lot of the issues that I talk
about in the book are of interest to the
ongoing conversation that does take
place here at the Center for Economic
Opportunity and those kinds of things
and and I think that the book has a has
a certain kind of impact on that plus
the fact that I don't ever really turn
down an invitation to talk about my own
book
so wow that plays its part and in this
in this decision as well what I thought
I would do is just talk briefly about
what I wanted to do with the book which
is also a way to kind of summarize the
major issues that inform the whole the
whole discussion there but I thought
what I would also do is talk about some
things some themes of it and issues that
are of interest to the kinds of
questions and again the kind of
conversation about the role of
multiculturalism the role of different
and often conflicting ethnic identities
in in the shaping of American
civilization and whatever whatever
happens with it from from this point on
and basically what I wanted to do with
the book was to try and explain how an
idea a way of talking about history a
way of talking about change about the
fate of societies and of civilizations a
way of talking that centered it centered
those discussions on in terms of
inevitable decline and degeneration to
show how this way of talking first came
into being how it originated and then
also to talk about how it came to has
come to permeate so many aspects of
modern culture turning up in all kinds
of surprising and unusual places
from from the modernism of the early
20th century all the way through on to
on two figures like figures bizarre
figures like the Unabomber and Vice
President Albert Gore the which I talk
about in detail in the in in in the book
this is and this way of talking what I
try to show in the book is that this way
of talking is reflected not just in the
kind of pessimism its notions of decline
not just in the kind of pessimism that
surveys opinion surveys always manage to
pick up from the American public in
which every time they're asked about 60%
or 70% of citizens believe that the
country is on the wrong track
and that they always seem to feel this -
regardless of what that track might be
that this just seems to be a natural
reaction to where to where in a sense
America seems to be going but I also
tried to show that this show how this
idea this way of talking this idea of
decline really underpins the movement of
various radical discontents in this
country whether you're talking about
radical environmentalism whether you're
talking about the post-modernism that
permeates so much of academic life and
intellectual discourse that takes place
and universities and the whole series of
movements that people usually talk about
usually described as multiculturalism
and what I wanted to show is that all of
these movements really share the same
basic assumption and that is is that
societies built on Western industrial
models are all doomed to destruction
that they all destroy human vitality and
creativity that industrial societies
modern industrial societies tear apart
communities and a kind of natural social
holes that had that had grown up before
industrialization and modern society
came into existence here and that in the
end in the end these modern industrial
societies have no values and that's a
key word here
throughout the book and the way in which
the notion of values becomes so is so
you know permeate so much of our
discussion here our current cultural
debates is itself in many ways
reflective of this idea of decline the
only thing really that modern industrial
societies produce it's assumed are
material goods which everyone has too
much of that anyway so that degree
doesn't serve any purpose and that end
also these you know so little armies of
shallow self-interested easily
manipulable little automatons who come
out of it what Herbert Marcuse are
called one-dimensional men and what
Frederick Nietzsche called the last man
the last man the last men who would
emerge at the end of at the end of
Western civilization human beings who
were really in Nietzsche's views more
insects than they were human beings and
that and then because of this then the
assumption is that in order to recover
some sense of humanity in order to
recover our sense of ourselves what we
have to do then is to turn away from the
West and modern Western values to look
for some kind of new dawn some sort of
new order that is going to replace its
inevitable collapse and that we built
upon the ruins the ruins of that
bankrupt and discredited civilization so
that's the overall trajectory of the
book but I also at the same time wanted
to show something else and that is how
the first people to become convinced
that Western civilization is in decline
and that idea by the way starts very
early the nineteenth century but these
people who saw the West as
systematically unraveling itself we're
not in any kind of way radicals that
then that includes people's
intellectuals such as Henry Adams in
this country but we're instead people
who were deeply concerned and
perhaps also deep a little confused
conservatives who were generally worried
about the direction that their own
societies were taking but that by
choosing to explain these changes in the
consequences in terms of decline in
terms of degeneration and the other
sorts of this other kinds of gloom and
doom forecast that went with it that
that that is sense that they had that
they ended up producing this view of the
West as systematically destroying itself
these are the people that I talk about
as the historical pessimists and this
was a matter of real concern that the
values the humane liberal values and
Western judeo-christian values that they
believed in we're coming under attack
and work were in a sense under a kind of
pressure that they couldn't withstand
and that by talking about these changes
in this way what they did what people
like Henry Adams did was to open the
door then to more radical solutions to
the problem to those who had plans and
agendas springing from this basic
assumption that the that if the modern
West is in decline it's because it
deserves to be in decline that the that
the fruits of it that the seeds of
destruction are there from the very
beginning and that therefore if we're
going to escape from that kind of
collapse we've really got to do then is
to look for that kind for a range of
alternatives these are the people I call
the cultural pessimists and so what I
was really trying to do was to show how
the historical pessimist arguments then
open the door create a situation in
which these more radical solutions
suddenly come forward as being more
acceptable and becoming becoming the
solution as I say the basic idea being
that the faster the West collapses then
the better the better for everyone
involved so this opened the way the
historical pessimism opened the way
first to racist doctrines and themes
which argued that the only way then to
say
civilization was through a radical
racial purity that the that the process
of civilization itself was creating a
society of racial mixtures and cultural
degradation and that only by protecting
white the original white Aryan race and
its virtues from that kind of pollution
this is the only way in which the West
was going to survive it paved the way
for race-based huge NX with that same
sense that the West was facing a crisis
at the end of the 19th century of
degeneracy thanks to industrial
civilization that therefore what had to
be done now was a I was to preserve the
race through various kinds of drastic
measures excluding those who are unfit
and unable to carry this burden of
civilization that the white race had
assumed for itself here and it also
opened the door for various radical
nationalist movements now which is what
happens is of course in Germany and in
many ways the Nazis are the first
European generation of cultural
pessimists of men raised in a 19th
century German intellectual tradition
that was permeated by this contempt for
booze raw civilization and its values
and also permeated by this fear that
industrial society was going to shatter
and disrupt the very precious sources
and sacred sources of of cultural and
creativity that were found in
traditional Germany that these would all
be destroyed through industrialization
that therefore that represent this this
is this threat this direct mortal threat
to Germany's own soul now that German
tradition that tradition of German
historical pessimism academic a cultural
criticism of the modern West is also
important I think for understanding our
own multiculturalist impulses today and
the reason I say that is that it did
this German tradition
comes to this country through a
particular and important channel namely
through the intellectual legacy of wev
Dubois the man who is of course today
the the prince viewed as the premier
african-american philosopher and thinker
but who is also in a sense the spiritual
godfather of of multiculturalism in its
various shapes and forms
now Dubois reputation as being this
profound an important figure is one I'm
not going to try and take away from him
it's it's built on very solid
foundations he was extremely prolific as
a journalist and as an author as durian
philosopher writer of fiction he was a
brilliant writer brilliant command of
prose he was a devastating critic of
prevalent white attitudes regarding race
and and and issues of segregation which
which Du Bois watched take place the
product the development of Jim Crow is
something which he which he watched come
into place during his lifetime but it's
also worth bearing in mind I think that
he is that his own assumptions the
assumptions from which he produced his
prodigious body of work and state were
the same assumptions is that of other
fan de siècle German academic thinkers
and this is where the ground reeked of
and I have a whole chapter on him there
too where I try and try and point this
out in detail and in back of any ways I
thought when I when I wrote it I was
remember thinking that this is this is
easily the most important part of the
book here this is the one that's going
to attract the most attention you know
stating that this major figure w/e
Dubois is really a kraut in a sense of
an intellectual intellectual German
philosopher and that these are the basis
of all his assumptions and of course
what happened was is that the reviewers
all didn't pay any attention at all to
it well all accept all accept them what
Weekly Standard Fred Segal did pick it
up and mention it in detail do boys's
experience exposure to German philosophy
came during his two years of study
at the University of Berlin 1892 through
94 and those years really changed his
life
it really had and he admitted this later
on it really had much more of an impact
on his intellectual development then his
years as an undergraduate at Harvard and
his work with leading teachers there
never really had the kind of
transformative impact that coming in
contact with with the German educational
system but also with the key professors
and intellectual movements there did
have so what was it he learned what was
it he did pick up from it for those
years in Germany well first of all he
did pick up this idea that the
Industrial West is really doomed if it
continues to follow this capitalist
model of development these were the
ideas the armchair socialists who
supervised his PhD thesis whose preached
this idea of the inevitable need for a
socialist state here as a means of
correcting this inevitable direction of
decline the rhetoric that they used to
talk about the impact of
industrialization on workers of workers
reduced to wage slaves these kinds of
terms the notion of industrialization is
slavery certainly had an impact on
Dubois in his way and touched deeply on
his own on his own understanding of the
relationship here between slavery in the
West and really had a big impact on
shaping that but also at the same time
they also the point that he picked up
was that industrial societies like
America sapped away the energy and
vitality of the people and culture that
were part of it and and here this German
dichotomy that was so important the
nineteenth century between soul
destroying civilization or civilization
versus this soul restoring culture or
coolt or this permeates all of DU boys's
work and it becomes a key distinction
and dichotomy in his own mind for
understanding the role of
african-americans are going to come to
play in Americans
as well here that in a sense that black
men and women in America find themselves
in the same position and are going to be
talked about by Dubois in the same way
as as these philosophers talked about
German peasants that in a sense they had
the same virtues of German peasants were
those of the virtues of blacks who
arrived here in America this kind of
inner creativity a kind of natural
vitality which their situation in
America in living in this kind of
oppressive culture and civilization
takes away and saps away and and again
that this is again a distinction
distinct from although a process which
was a part and parcel of slavery but it
is also something which the end of
slavery and emancipation does not end
that that process of soul destroying
civilization grinds on grinds on whether
free or slave and and of course Du Bois
term for this kind of natural creativity
and natural vitality soul Lucy takes
place arises also from this German
context German cultural critics had been
using that term souls Aylor for a long
time long before Du Bois appeared on the
scene and again it was the idea of soul
was to be understood this natural
vitality or soul was to be understood in
racial terms that infect each race each
race had its own little bundle of
vitality here which in the case of
blacks was still uncontaminated by
contact with you see this destructive
civilization the Western capitalism and
all of the kinds of institutions that it
creates so what do boys did was to take
up these themes and to use them to
intervene on the African American
intellectual debates that were raging at
the turn of the century
and he really reshapes them at a very
very crucial time he's going to use
those ideas not just to discredit Booker
T Washington's view of how blacks are to
assimilate into modern American society
and the food Dubois the whole notion of
assimilation of assimilation in
Washington's terms and that is blacks
becoming active willing participants in
the free enterprise capitalist system
was for him this is the last thing in
the world you want to do you don't want
to attach yourself to the
soul-destroying
mechanism at all you want to break free
it from it you want to find alternatives
from it so he uses it first to discredit
Booker T Washington but he's also going
to use it to reject the earlier models
of black nationalism of figures like
Alexander crummell
and Henry Turner these were black
nationalists of an earlier generation
they had been passionately committed to
black nationalism they were passionately
committed to a sense of racial pride but
they had also insisted that if blacks
were going to change their status in the
world that they also needed to
acknowledge the values of white
civilization and it's institutions
science technology capitalism and of
course also the values of Christianity
and the judeo-christian tradition both
chromel and Turner were bishops in the
Methodists Episcopalians and and for
them white civilization also included
necessarily included these Christian
this Christian framework as well so a
Dubois is going to do is reject all of
that it'll return it and it's
interesting to speculate I think how the
history of black nationalism would have
been different if it had not turned its
back at the on this what de story ins
call the civilizations
deesis this idea that dissimulation
includes a kind of a kind of
assimilation in a cultural and an a
value sense as well as one of in terms
of political and social mobility that it
also has to involve this embrace of a
larger cultural mobility but Du Bois
makes sure and the growth of his
influence makes sure that that does not
happen because Du Bois was convinced
that the West and the industrial
colonial empires that had clustered
around it were now finished in many ways
his view about the West here is very
much akin to Oswald Spangler's the
overlap between Spengler's decline of
the west and Dubois writings on these
same themes is really remarkable and
they really do they really do fit
together very well
instead what Dubois saw in the future
was the rise of what he called the
darker nations to global power first in
the case of the yellow races and we have
to remember that Du Bois was writing at
a time when Japan was emerging as a
major player in colonial conflicts and
on the world stage at the turn of the
century well but then but then after the
yellow races had risen to power then it
would be then would be black Africa's
turn and Du Bois is an ocean the whole
his famous phrase that this is the that
we live in the the age of the color line
but we have to realize is that for
Dubois this was a color line
the balance of power along which was now
about to shift in his mind but these
empires these empires of the dark
nations would all be based upon again
this racial vitalist model in which
technology material wealth our tools
tools to be used by a racial elite as a
means by which to to gain the levers of
power and to direct them here and would
be these empires also would draw upon
the this element of the Marxist model
and again for Du Bois as for later
multiculturalism Marxism z' appeal is
simply that it is in fact a rev
Ellucian arey doctrine that it is
anti-capitalist
and therefore implicitly anti-western
that the use that Marxism is going to
play in these kinds of this kind of
development is as a as a kind of anti
model to this larger industrial Western
cultural and economic complex and it's
really kind of interesting to see how
the will how the rise of radical racial
movements beginning in the 60s follow
also the rise of Du Bois his reputation
as he moves from a period of time when
she was really in the shadows which was
the 40s and 50s and suddenly becomes the
great model and the intellectual mentor
for a whole generation of black radical
starting first with the black power and
and figures like like Malcolm X then in
then with the development of
african-american studies and and and an
afro centrosome and now being treated
today as a kind of spokesman for the for
a black Atlantic consciousness being put
in these kinds of large or postmodern
terms as someone who who had who has
comes up with a new a new alternative
vision for individuals and community as
well as culture that really in the end
Du Bois is the intellectual godfather
for all these movements which celebrate
the essential vital is of the person of
color and again I want to point out this
is the link again to this sort of German
view of the role of Kotor of natural
vitality here which Western society
takes down destroys and undermines in
these ways and of course these kinds of
movements this this movement of racial
vitality includes not just not just
movements in black now radical black
politics but we also see it in movements
like la raza
for example is a perfectly good example
and in fact their vision of a kind of
southwestern Hispanic Empire stretching
out has enormous affinities and very
similar
and coached in very similar terms to the
way in which people like marcus garvey
talked about a a black empire in in
africa in fact marcus garvey is really a
good example of how Dubois his influence
works in this story because on the one
hand Garvey had this strong emphasis on
the back to Africa movement of blacks
actually physically returning to Africa
which Dubois by by the by about 1910 and
really abandoned as being as being
unrealistic
he also Garvey also preached very much
the preach the the need for intellectual
and economic advancement which of theme
by the way which Louis Farrakhan has now
picked up and has made as central to him
and is one of the reasons why very often
he's treated as being as a sort of
sympathetic figure in certain regards
certain aspects of his ideas being
treated sympathetically here but again
it's important to point out that this
notion of economic advancement for
blacks was seen as a way not to make
black people rich but instead but to
make them powerful that wealth is again
seen simply as a lever for power not for
individual advancement not for
individual enrichment and pursuit of
individual happiness but as a means to
gain political power in this way and for
Garvey
that means to power was to destroy white
supremacy to shatter the bonds of white
supremacy and instead to create this
master black race as he said a grand
racial hierarchy and an empire on which
he said the Sun will never set again
drawing upon that kind of those kinds of
imperialist models here in order to in
order to project a future a future for
for the darker races well that kind of
that kind of overblown rhetoric there's
no longer so present now and the
multiculturalist debate people don't
talk about creating creating grand
racial hierarchies
although it survives a question people
like Farrakhan and some of the some of
the some of the afro centrist but this
whole way of seeing history and seeing
American society in terms of group
histories in terms of group identities
here all reflect that Du Bois Ian's
legacy and again also reflect that
German legacy here that what we're
dealing with them becoming when we
confront these kinds of issues in the
multiculturalist debate are essentially
essentially nineteenth-century ways of
talking about society and race and then
if you take that away if you take away
that that implicit decline ISM and the
assumptions that underpin it that that
the whole multicultural empires kind of
collapses of its own weight and I think
in many ways this is the this is a last
point I want to make and it's an
important one and that is to and that is
that the goals of multiculturalism of
radical multiculturalism again have
nothing to do with questions of
assimilation here or or inclusion
because it views from the very beginning
it views Western society as corrupt as
soul-destroying and all of its
mechanisms as as agents of this kind of
corrupting corrupting power
now the question really for the
multiculturalist debate is the question
not about assimilation or inclusion but
about power of how to construct a
patchwork quilt here out of American
society in which eventually eventually
and in begin because inevitably white
bourgeois capitalism the pieces that it
contributes here are going to eventually
unravel and disappear that in a sense
that multiculturalism can take the
offensive and and and and and have
confidence in its goals because in the
end it's going to win you see in the end
as Dubois had wreck had had had asserted
that the the future of him
you see belongs to the people of color
and that that out of that will come will
come the emergence then of a new kind of
civilization when the West when the West
and its various apparatus is for control
have disappeared until the issue of
assimilation and the question of how
those kinds of issues will finally be
resolved I think in the end has to come
down to a really close debate and a
critical analysis of those precisely
those kinds of assumptions that underpin
it and and that drive forward is forces
in this kind of ongoing debate and that
is its assumptions about the West's
assumptions about the the direction of
history and its assumptions about the
nature of very nature of civil society
that the that the virtues that civil
society that modern industrial society
can create its its social mobility for
example in Geographic mobility its
ability to to generate large amounts of
material affluence
its ability to empower individuals to
enjoy freedom of all sorts and in in in
various new and unexpected ways and that
that notion of freedom has itself a
fundamental moral value all of these
things are all these are virtues which
are from the beginning screened out from
this kind of debate and the notion the
idea of a theory of history which could
incorporate those virtues while at the
same time recognizing its shortcomings
may be a way not just for enable
Americans to regain a sense of
confidence about the future but it may
also be a way to gain a new angle in a
new direction on this larger
multiculturalist debate that's going on
now
well thank you very much the usual order
now is to open the floor up to questions
and I will let professor Herman
recognize you but I would ask those of
you who want to ask questions please
identify yourselves
you spoke this afternoon what's greater
length in your book about various
thinkers who are inspired by Marx
markussi in the front for school this
afternoon Dubois and so on
I found it curious that you had no
chapter in your book on Marx and I think
had you had such a chapter had you focus
more directly more explicitly in a
greater length on Mars I think you might
have had to modify your opening remarks
today and also a theme that goes through
the book that the Animus of all of these
thinkers these what are we calling them
Declan asur declined us or whatever
their their animus against modern
industrial society I think you would
then have to say that yes to be sure
that's true of some of them but for a
great many others and I think
particularly for the moderns the Animus
is against modern industrial capitalist
society and as capitalist and as crucial
in the case of Marx for example who did
not propose to transcend industrialism
and I wondered I wondered what why you
did not in fact have like why you didn't
have that chapter on Marx well you know
that's an excellent question and it's
one that runs through my mind not just
now but from time to time and and it's a
and it's an issue which in the end was I
think also an intellectual one and that
was that that for me the the question
about Marx Marx really belongs as a as a
theorist to the school of historical
progressives and the proof the prophets
of progress that I talked about in the
hundred
the book and I mentioned marks and
talked about his theories there and it's
precisely I think because he did see the
end of capitalism as creating not
something that was non-western or that
would reject the kinds of values of
industrial society and the
transformations that had taken place but
that would in a sense transcend them
raised them to another level and enable
large numbers of other people to enjoy
who could not he believed could not
enjoy them under a under the existing
capitalist status quo and that in the
end I think Marx does belong to this and
does come at the in a kind of odd way to
the end of this sort of liberal humanist
tradition it permeates his own views
about many of these kinds of issues here
and as we know there is a marxist
humanist tradition that does kind of
emerge out of that Marxist point of view
here now Marx is going to become an
important tool I think for those who
want to talk about capitalist society as
declining as degenerating he provides
fuel for the argument and in a way he
also creates a kind of larger
apocalyptic framework for this that the
end of capitalist civilization is itself
inevitable there's a kind of
inevitability to these historical
processes that that a new order will
necessarily arise from what happens
after that collapse takes place and of
course he also shares this other
ingredient with the with the kinds of
cultural pessimists that I have talked
about here and that is his tendency to
see human beings caught in these
processes as being in a sense
essentially sort of helpless pawns in
what takes place that history is a
process that goes on regardless of how
individuals play their parts and how
they see these kinds of events taking
place that the cultural pessimists and
like the Marxist sees history is
something that's done to people as
opposed to seeing history as something
in which
individuals act on the world on the
basis of their assumptions and beliefs
and that basic historical assumption is
one I think that builds a strong bridge
a strong bridge between between those
two those two kinds of movements how
very interesting such a chapter would be
because it tells us how very ambiguous
Marx's legacy has been very much so yeah
I mean the Marx is right there and that
enlightenment progressive is tradition
indeed in a very utopian tradition that
utopianism means that he has to
transcend in a sense the Western
civilization as we have known it and he
has funny to create a new kind of man
which brings us right into to our into
the kind of marveling Leninist yes and
not and into an anti Western
civilization tradition but I think it
would have made made for a very powerful
chapter book
I'm a National Legal Center for the
public campus know if you're if you're
born in an airplane and you live your
life in an airplane you're gonna be very
interested in theories of crashes that's
just that and I think here in the West
we're conscious of the fact that we are
part of the civilization that has been
enormously successful and we look back
in the in the past and we see that there
have been crashes it's not an unheard-of
thing there have been lots of empires
over over the centuries that that have
crashed and I wonder - to what extent
in in other civilizations non-western
civilizations there have been comparable
theories of decline is as I'm suggesting
a theory of decline sort of part of
human nature and an inevitable part of
being in a civilization where you can
see that well we've gone up what goes up
must come down and there are a variety
of ways which we might come down and so
you have different intellectuals
speculating on how this part of our
civilization or other well you know is
inevitably doomed to collapse and
sometimes they're right and sometimes
are wrong
yeah I mean I don't know if it's
necessarily natural to human species but
it does seem to be something that
appears in almost every sophisticated
culture or civilization that sense and I
talked about this in the introduction in
some detail that sense that with the way
things our forebears did did it were a
lot better you know and that they were
just a lot more better equipped than we
are and really superior and all these
other kinds of things that we've sort of
watched the sort of ongoing decay about
it
part of it may be simply just the way in
which human beings I think experience
change in their themselves as human
beings as you lose certain kinds of
physical powers as time goes on there is
this sort of
that you know what the way one had lived
before was with those kinds of powers to
be able to to do things that that you
can't anymore has a kind of acquires a
certain kind of a lure to it and that
this becomes sort of transferred and
talking about the ways in which we
understand how groups work and interact
societies nations empires and then too
and then project it onto the sort of
grander scheme of civilizations that
somehow a you know a link that's
established by historical tradition that
ties generations over hundreds of years
even a millennia or more and of course
that's a part of permanent part of the
West as well Western ideas from the
ancients through Middle Ages to the
Reformation the whole notion of
apocalyptic vision of the end of end of
the world all of these kinds of things
reflect similar decline is kinds of
ideas here and in some cases generate a
sense of that kind of you know apathy
and resignation that goes with it
I think the difference though that comes
with the 18th century and was really
with the Enlightenment and the
Enlightenment is the starting point for
my book and some it really and it's also
the starting point for this sense of
ambiguity about decline the ambiguities
that are built into the notion of of how
weather history progresses or declines
is the idea that the is that that is
that the is that the ultimate reality to
which history in our events in our lives
are to be held accountable is in the
here and now in the secular time and
that the and that the that the
realization and and the kind of
transformation of our lives for the
better that lifts us out from the kind
of you know the sort of a love tears in
which we find ourselves the idea that
that that that kind of lifting out is
something that takes place now in the
future this is what the idea of progress
brings or likewise that the collapse and
the winding down that goes with it is
also something that takes place in the
in the
now as opposed to something we look for
a transcendent reality religious a
religious escape and breakthrough
to make this kind of transformation this
is the big change that comes in the 19th
century and the rejection on the one
hand a reaction against the idea of
progress things aren't getting better
they're getting worse but also at the
same time but also at the same time this
feeling that yes things are getting
worse but I have a better idea of what
we can do from here which is how the
historical pessimists become turns into
the cultural pessimist that I can
realize that greater idea in here and
now by our neck the next society we
create whether it's a Marxist utopia or
whether it's a racial vitalist vision of
the future or whatever kinds of whatever
kinds of models models are going to be
used to to explain that
yeah go ahead they don't come around
here oh yeah IMAX great
is there some common reason or reasons
why some groups latch on to his idea of
decline and others don't
well that's a that's an important
question I guess certain groups are
certain individuals in any case
certainly from the point of view of
people like Henry Adams in this country
and people like Jakob Burkhart and
Europe in the 19th century these were
people for whom the big sweeping changes
the 19th century really gave them a
sense of displacement that the world had
really changed in ways that the where
the world around them and really become
foreign to them and all these people
suddenly surfacing from the kind of
lower orders that they had never seen
before the sort of an enormous increase
and sudden appearance of this sort of
capitalist wealth of a sort that they
that they had not recognized or seen
before and certainly that sense of being
displaced in one's own society and the
context in which one finds itself makes
it easier to latch on to explanations or
rationalizations as to why this is
taking place but at the same time of
course the whole point is is that
there's a kind of paradox here because
on the one hand you are interpreting the
changes in experiences that you're going
through and they have an impact on
shaping your view of the society in
which you live but at the same time of
course the ways in which you interpret
those things depend on the assumptions
you bring to it from the very beginning
here and from my point of view from the
point of view of what I'm talking about
as far as modern culture go how modern
culture functions and is permeated by
these decliners notions is that this is
in a sense that becomes a process of a
kind of intellectual trickle-down effect
here of a kind of of a kind of cultural
conditioning in which the terms of
debate and the ways in which we
understand these issues are being
constantly framed constantly framed
along those either historical pessimist
assumptions or cultural pessimist
assumptions so no I don't think there's
some kind of you know natural mechanism
that explains it because you can have
displaced people in
society take immigrants to this country
the turn of the century who don't at all
have that sense that the society in
which they're engaged in this you know
in inevitable decline and in decrepitude
quite the opposite
there is in a sense instead there's an
enormous influx of energy and engagement
with that society that comes with it so
it's I don't know if there's any
particular mechanism that's at work here
that that brings people to it it brings
people to this notion of decline but
certainly you can see I think and I try
and lay out on the and the books what
the consequence is what the consequences
can be yeah John Fante Alexis de
Tocqueville institution they have two
related questions how would you fit
something say like Robert Bork's
slouching towards Gomorrah and your
taxonomy he's more or less a cultural
decline us but he suggests returning to
the presence of jeremiad returning to
the principles of the West rather than
rejecting the myth the West connected
the second question is to what extent is
multiculturalism not about race or
culture but about ideology in the sense
and ideology of Western progressives an
instrument of Western progressives to
essentially balkanize into ethnic groups
peoples and then in the sense what's
needed then of course is a
centralization a new elite a new clash
that essentially rules the roost and
form of some form of utopianism as
discussed to what extent is this valid
that's an interesting point Bork's book
I'm not gonna talk about Bork's book
that's first of all I am going to say
simply this and that that when talking
about these kinds of issues
conservatives always have to be careful
and that is that there is when you start
to use that vocabulary of decline ISM
and start bringing in these kinds of
images and metaphors and begin to talk
about society and its institutions in
these sorts of terms that you do lend
yourself vulnerable to various other
kinds of more radical solutions
and-and-and-and proposed directions for
those those institutions here and that
in many ways the the same thing happened
with with Paul Kennedy's book two on the
decline and fall of the great powers
that when you start talking about
American society in terms of these
decline that the only people you really
in the end make happy are the people who
are looking forward to that decline into
that end which is not to say there's
nothing to worry about
that's not to say that Bork may not have
you know valid points about certain
kinds of things that there are things to
worry about it and to be concerned about
to take action towards it but I think
that in some regards the that attitude
and we've seen it happen in the
nineteenth century
that that attitude of historical
pessimism does create an environment in
which these cultural pessimist solutions
begin to move began to move to the fore
as for your other question regard to
whether multiculturalism is not in fact
a kind of statist you know a kind of
hidden state ism that's at work here on
the part of Western progressives I
suppose that's there's a there's an
ingredient to that that there is this
kind of danger that where
multiculturalism will lead us is to a
situation that you get in something like
you know the Ottoman Empire with the
with a meal a system in which you've got
religious and ethnic minorities who are
who are led by a form at community at
ghettoize community headed by certain
accepted leaders who are able to deal
and serve as power brokers with the with
the centralized power holders and then
what you get is this kind of this close
relationship then in which the
centralized power distributes favors to
various of these ethnic groups in
exchange for obedience to the laws there
is I suppose some danger that that is
what's at work and there may be some
people who are aware of what's of what's
taking place here but the but the multi
but how multiculturalism itself views
the West and how the figures who are
engaged in this kind of discussion is
really what is really the issue that
I've
interesting and that I've been that I've
been trying to address here - I was
Richard clingy I went to school in
France I don't on focus on you but the
people of my generation who studied this
sort of subject shall know us and action
process is very large and highly
interrogative question I just wonder how
you fit in it well Lois I think is
someone who I talk about him there very
briefly in the discussion about the
French prophets of doom they in the kind
of the background - what will happen
later on in the 20s and 30s and in Paris
here Morris is a classic declines he's a
historical pessimist in all these other
kinds of ways and he sews again this
sort of this sort of pessimism a kind of
undermining of self-confidence in the
French Republic or even in the
possibility of the OU his own political
program being being coming into
existence here there's no way in which
even the French monarchy could come into
the French monarchy that could come into
existence would be one that Maha's would
not have recognized and we've refused to
have turned to some other kind of
political system instead but that kind
of that sort of decline is view that
refusal to participate in modern in
normal political institutions such as
they existed in France again played a
part in creating an intellectual climate
a climate first among intellectuals on
the right but then later on with
intellectuals on the left that again
that Western bushwa society is is
inevitably doomed and is going to have
to be overturned and that in a sense
that almost anything that takes its
place is going to be better than what
we've got
and last yeah I was curious I feel like
you ever really explained why this time
it's so different because I mean the
Greeks work terribly it Socrates Plato
and they you know viciously criticize
their own societies didn't I mean didn't
necessarily believe in sort of an
otherworldly recompense for what happens
here which is what you say change in the
night in the 18th century so I just feel
like I don't really understand what has
changed so much that we would have a
sort of vicious turning on our own
society I mean how does the the one
explain the other Oh in terms of the
vicious turning well that could be
that's a slightly different point what I
think let me try again
we should replace it as opposed to it to
depression that something we like has
gone wrong that's right but don't forget
the cultural pessimist is in the bay at
the end he is building upon an
historical pessimist argument namely
that the West is winding down but the
cultural pessimist is saying there's
something that lies beyond that not lies
beyond in terms of a transcendent
reality which is where you see they
would differ from let's say a Christian
or a judeo-christian tradition or or a
Plato or Socrates view and that is is
that the world is the way it is that's
all there is to it and if you are
looking for a happiness if you are
looking for a virtue you have to move
outside of that what the cultural
pessimist is saying no don't do that
that's lost cause anyway it's an
illusion instead that lost virtue that
sense of lost morality and lost values
can be recovered in the here and now you
see through secular historical processes
and through political processes and
that's the key difference is is that the
cultural pessimist is building on
historical on this idea of decline but
he's creating a new progressive vision
to emerge out of it a new progressive
version that's going to come but which
you see has to detach itself entirely
from
from that from the moraband predecessor
the Moorabbin prototype
thank you very much
I'd like to say a few words to Professor
Herman about your chapter on
multiculturalism because one of the
reasons that we were interested in
having you here is the whole way in
which multiculturalism has infected not
just higher education which is where we
read about it most often and where we
see some of its most radical forms but
multiculturalism in public schools in
the United States and and notions that
were once the purview of intellectuals
in ivory towers are now very much the
education of most school children in
America today and these ideas of decline
and particularly the way in which
multiculturalism plays into the ideas of
decline and the profound anti
Americanism that is sometimes found in
these programs I think is something that
I know concerns us here at the Center
for equal opportunity this whole idea
that children must be indoctrinated in
the notion of the evils of the West and
the failures of Western civilization and
the way in which although many of the
multiculturalists talk about inclusion
as their purpose and moving many
children from from different racial and
ethnic backgrounds into the mainstream
of America the actual doctrines that are
promoted the actual materials that are
used the actual models that are put up
are often very much in the in a
different direction and I think your
book did an excellent job in in that
chapter of talking about those themes so
I want to thank you again very much and
thank all of you for coming and invite
you again to our next book luncheon
which John do we have we don't have a
date yet set but you'll be getting
invitations from us all thank you very
much
[Applause]
in a minute a look at the 22nd annual
Washington antiquarian book fair and
later consumer advocate Ralph Nader
talks about